[Musique]
la nature nous donne parfois la chance
d'observer de rares phénomènes
d'adoption chez les animaux mais celui
qui se déroule en ce moment dans saint
laurent est un cas unique un arval au
coeur d'une communauté de béluga
[Musique]
dans l'histoire animal comme dans
l'histoire humaine il y a des
explorateurs qui s'aventurent hors de
leur territoire
à l'été 2020 une baleine à bosse est
remonté jusqu'à montréal
ailleurs on a vu des bélougas égaré
fréquenter des eaux et des endroits où
on ne les voit jamais
c'est béluga là quand ils se retrouvent
en dehors de leurs airs habituels il se
retrouve seul perdu isolé et souvent ils
vont se mettre dans le trouble
les histoires de ces animaux et
garrigues finissent en général assez mal
maillage dans des filets un pacte avec
des navires mais l'histoire qui suit
c'est l'exception et ça se passe ici
même dans le fleuve saint laurent
notre première rencontre avec le narval
remontera 2016
surprise et étonnement qu'est ce qu'il
fait là
l'intrus est un art valent un cousin des
bélougas
sensiblement de la même taille mais plus
foncé avec une défense qui lui donne des
airs de licorne quand il est arrivé est
d'un très jeune animal sur les balcons
estimé autour de 2 5 6 ans cc c'est très
très approximatif comme estimations
c'est par la taille de l'animal la
longueur de sa défense la présence la
défense treillis un peu son sexe là on
n'a pas de doute que on a affaire un
jeune mâle ici on compte environ 170
mille narval dans le monde
règle générale on lui trouve à l'est du
groenland dans le détroit de davis la
mer de baffin dans l'archipel arctique
et au vent d'ouest de la déduction
difficile de dire avec certitude d'où
vient celui du saint laurent ce ne
serait pas le premier narval s'y pointer
mais ce serait le premier à rester dans
le saint-laurent depuis plus de six ans
et aucun doute c'est le même individu
qui était paru en 2016 la question s'est
imposé aux autres bébés google aux
invités à rester sont ni répondra jamais
mais c'est la chose la plus
extraordinaire de cette aventure leur
combat et qui se continue avec le normal
c'est son son intégration en quelque
sorte dans dans le tissu social d'une
autre espèce
[Musique]
pour l'instant c'est davantage un sujet
de curiosité que sujet d'étude ceci dit
des images fortes eu étendront vont
permettre de suivre l'évolution de sa
condition physique
mais aujourd'hui on voit une image qui
beaucoup plus gros je ne sais pas qu'est
ce qu'ils mangent mais clairement y
mange bien marge suffisamment pour se
maintenir
au delà de se nourrir et de se faire des
amis ce normal à bien d'autres défis ce
qui m'était ou bruit du trafic maritime
et communiquer avec les autres béluga
est-ce que ce navale est en train
d'apprendre le langage des bélougas
esclave
outils de communication sont assez
proches pour se faire comprendre ça
c'est des questions auxquelles on n'a
pas de père fait pense pour l'instant
comme on le fait ici pour de suivi des
bélougas on a pu prélever un minuscule
échantillons de peau et de gras du
narval il contient sa signature
génétique
si jamais une ses choix
et qu'on retrouvait sa carcasse mais
qu'on pouvait pas leur reconnaître
visuellement sa signature génétique nous
permettrait de faire la connexion si ce
jeune narval se reproduisait dans la
population de bijoux gobain on a la
signature génétique la fondation de
cette nouvelle filiation atb voudront
se reproduire avec des bélougas
et oui la preuve vient du danemark après
l'étude de mystérieux crâne récupéré par
un chasseur
au début des années 90 ce crâne a été
repérée chez un chasseur qui avait tué
l'animal à l'ouest du groenland
quelques années plus tôt
et ce crâne avait un air bizarre
le crâne de l'animal a à la fois quelque
chose du narval du béluga des dents dans
la mâchoire supérieure et inférieure
comme le béluga m'aider dans légèrement
torsadé orientés plutôt à l'horizontale
comme les dents qui constitue la défense
du narval
entreposés pendant plus de 25 ans au
musée d'histoire naturelle du danemark
de nouvelles techniques d'analysé en
génomique comparative relance l'intérêt
pour cette étrange crâne si on veut in
est une autre même si l'adn du crâne
était très endommagée
en utilisant des techniques pour étudié
l'adn ancien
on a pu tirer de l'information de ce
crâne et retracer son origine
est ce qu'ils ont découvert les a
renversés
[Musique]
on a pu confirmer que c'était un hybride
de première génération
sa mère était un art val
et son père devait être le béluga
et voici à quoi aurait pu ressembler ce
mal issu du croisement entre ces deux
espèces du moins si on se fie aux
croquis imaginé par l'illustrateur
danois marcus biolay
c'est ce qui nous ramène dans le saint
laurent et si on vous parle de ce narval
aujourd'hui ceux qui l'approchent de sa
maturité sexuelle la maturité sexuelle
survient chez les piliers chez les
en-avants probablement à peu près au
même âge autour de 12 ans
12 et 16 ans pour pour les marques mais
ça coupe les mêmes pour les bélougas
n'est pas si simple il n'y a qu'une
femelle disponible pour 3 mal ce défi
auquel il va faire face baleiniers
considérable il faut qu'ils aient accès
à des femelles et ses taxes et l'oeil et
gagner souvent en équipe
difficile de prévoir la suite de cette
histoire ou même l'évolution des
rapports entre les deux espèces sans
savoir combien de temps une passera dans
le fleuve on sait néanmoins que les
narvals peut vivre des dizaines d'années
peux honnêtement dire que j'espère
qu'ils vont rester pour ces situations
intéressantes qui qui qui est une belle
opportunité d'en apprendre plus sur la
vie sociale des bijoux gras peut être
pas des narvals mais débiles ou en soi
ni si je devais parier
moi je crois que ce job nerval là est là
pour rester
[Musique]